你一定有
碰到這種情況
台股明明在漲
但是你手上
一堆股票
不但沒怎麼賺錢
有一些
還一直跌
這一切
其實都只有
一個原因
你的股票太弱了
給我5分鐘
我教你
怎麼幫手上的股票
做一次健康檢查
幫你汰弱留強
強的股票
我們留下來
弱的股票
就要趕快把它斷捨離
影片看到最後
我再給你一個
實戰的選股法
讓你每天開盤前
只花5分鐘
就可以抓到
潛力的飆股
讓你的錢投資在
效益最高的地方
我是小王子
20年資深交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我們先講一個
最重要的問題
為什麼一定要
淘汰弱勢的股票
很多人都有一個誤區
就是會覺得
都已經賠那麼多了
現在賣掉
不就真的虧了嗎
但你忽略了一件事
資金是有限的
你的錢卡在這裡
不但沒有辦法去買
真正會上漲的強勢股
你手上的這些
持續下跌的股票
要回本解套的可能性
也非常小
因為股票跌得越多
要回本需要的漲幅
就會跟著
成倍增加
一檔一百元的股票
下跌 20％之後
股價變成80塊
但從80塊
要再漲回100塊
就不是
漲 20％就夠了
是要漲 25％
那如果
跌得更多呢
同樣是
100塊的股票
如果下跌 40％
股價剩下60塊
這時候從60塊
再漲回原本的100塊
就要上漲 66.7％
所以你會發現
股票跌得越深
想要回到
原本的價格
需要的漲幅
就要更高
前陣子
有個朋友問我
他有一檔股票
已經虧損很久了
到底要不要賣掉
我一看他的虧損76％
這代表至少要漲
316％以上
才有可能回本
這真的不太可能
而且研究發現
過去三個月到一年
表現很好的股票
接下來的平均表現
也會比其他股票更好
這個現象
叫做動能
就像滾雪球一樣
強勢的股票
會越滾越大
弱勢的股票
卻還在原地踏步
所以重點來了
要判斷哪些股票
是真的弱勢
需要斷捨離
最完整的方法
可以分成
三個關卡
第一關
你要先判斷
現在台股的趨勢
最簡單的方法
就是看
台灣加權指數的
60日均線
台灣加權指數
也叫做大盤
代表台股
整體的表現
均線指的是
一段時間之內
大家購買股票的
平均成本
60日均線
也叫做季線
你也可以把它視為
台股的生命線
如果大盤長期
都在這條線的上方
代表整體台股
偏向上漲
也有人把它叫做多頭
或是牛市
相反的
如果大盤長期
都低於這條線
就代表
整體台股的方向
幾乎都是處於下跌
也有人把它叫做空頭
或是熊市
在多頭行情裡
你會看到加權指數
幾乎都在季線之上
而且季線
還會持續地往上走
像今年的4月到6月
就是這種情況
整個台股
幾乎都是在漲
差別只是
漲多漲少而已
這種時候
你的任務就是
積極地淘汰弱勢股
把錢拿去投資
更強的股票
搭上整個
行情的順風車
但是
股價不可能一直漲
如果大盤指數
開始下跌
而且一直都在
季線的下方
這就是
很多人最怕的
空頭行情
在空頭行情裡
一樣要淘汰弱勢股
但淘汰的目的
不是為了
買更強的股票
是為了
保留更多的現金
等景氣開始好轉
再重新買進
一般來說
在多頭的行情裡
我會建議預留
10％到 20％的現金
空頭行情就要準備
總資金的 40％
到 70％的現金
所以重點來了
第二關
我要怎麼知道
手裡的股票
到底是強還是弱
這裡要特別提醒
股票的強弱
不是看你的報酬率
股票虧錢
不代表它弱
有可能只是因為
你剛好
在行情很差的時候買
有賺錢
不代表它強
有可能只是
現在整個行情很好
其他股票都在暴漲
它卻只漲了一點點
那一樣算弱勢股
所以最簡單的方法
就是拿它和
台灣加權指數
來做比較
看看它的表現
有沒有超過大盤
這個道理就像
如果全班平均80分
你考了70分
代表你的表現不好
但如果全班平均
只有40分
你卻考了60分
那你的表現
還是很好
那要怎麼看
股價的表現
有沒有贏過大盤
很多網站都有
個股比較的功能
只要輸入
你手上的股票
網站就會顯示
這檔股票的漲跌狀況
以及它和
台股大盤的比較
要看多長的時間
我一般會選擇
三個月到半年
比較完之後
我們要把結果
分為三種狀況
第一種狀況
這檔股票的報酬率
明顯比大盤還要強
那不用多說
它就是強勢股
可以先繼續抱著
第二種情況
就是這檔股票的表現
幾乎比大盤還要弱
甚至有時候
大家都在漲
它反而還在下跌
這種股票
我們就要把它放到
弱勢股清單
等一下再來決定
要不要來淘汰它
最後一種狀況
就是看不出來
它的表現
好像跟大盤差不多
或是之前很弱
最近突然變強
這種股票
可以先放進
待觀察名單
清單建立好之後
就進入
最關鍵的第三關
這些弱勢的股票
是不是真的要淘汰
如果要賣
又應該
什麼時候賣
第一個判斷標準
很簡單
看均線
如果是在多頭行情
大部分的股票
都在賺錢
那我們可以看
20日線
也叫做月線
如果是空頭行情
因為大部分的股票
其實都在下跌
我們就稍微
放寬標準
改看60日的季線
如果你手上的股票
最近的股價持續地
在對應的均線之下
代表它正處於
下跌的趨勢
接下來比較容易
越跌越深
就可以先賣出
如果股價
還在均線之上
就可以等到它的股價
跌到均線的下方
再賣出
如果你真的覺得
這檔股票很有機會
捨不得賣掉
你可以在
跌破月線的時候
先賣掉一半
如果連季線也跌破
那就真的代表
這檔股票
現在真的很弱
你就不要再執迷不悟了
趕快把剩下的一半
也賣掉
第二個判斷標準
就是看壓力線
所謂的壓力
有點像是
股價短線的天花板
就算我們跳得再高
頭上還是
會有東西頂住
在股市裡
如果一個價格
之前有很多人買在那裡
當股價漲到
壓力附近的時候
這些人為了回本
就會趕快把股票賣掉
這個時候就會出現
很大的賣出力量
導致股價不容易漲上去
甚至開始反轉下跌
你可以把最近幾次
股價上漲之後
反轉下跌的位置
連起來
就會形成一條壓力線
當股價連續幾次
都無法
突破壓力的時候
短期內
要麼是漲不上去
卡在那裡
不然就是
開始下跌
與其繼續等
還不如把錢
拿去投資
更有機會的股票
自從我教很多人
要替換弱勢股之後
偶爾還是會收到抱怨
有的人跟我說
老師 我上次賣掉某某股票
結果我一賣
它就漲了10幾％
但這位同學
沒有想到的是
他最近買的
兩檔股票
收益都將近 50％
如果不先把
弱勢的股票賣掉
你哪裡有錢
可以買這兩檔飆股呢
另外一種
常見的說法是
有同學會跟我說
這家公司
營收、獲利、產業
都很好
我相信它以後
一定可以漲回來
在這裡
我要跟大家
分享一個觀念
用營收、產業、資訊
來判斷股票的價值
這個叫做
基本面選股
基本面
本身沒有問題
但基本面
應該是你
投資這檔股票的理由
而不是買了以後
拒絕認賠的理由
很多人
喜歡講巴菲特
講價值投資
認為只要公司是好的
就應該長期持有
不要害怕短期下跌
但卻忽略了一個
最重要的問題
你跟巴菲特
最大的區別
在於他有
足夠的資訊
跟研究團隊
能夠判斷
這家公司的價值
有沒有被高估
但你沒有
很多人會說
這家公司的財報
很優秀
現在的股價
被低估了
卻沒有意識到
財報只能告訴你
過去這家公司很賺錢
至於現在的狀況如何
甚至未來的發展
只看財報
不可能知道
2011年
宏達電的營收
4000多億
成長率 67％
股價1200多塊
你只看財報會覺得
這家公司的經營狀況
非常好
但實際上
宏達電的營收、利潤
跟市場的策略
這個時候
就已經出現問題了
但很多人還是覺得
這家公司一定行
結果兩年之後
股價從1200多塊
一路跳水到50塊
所以投資股票
不是靠信仰
買了之後
就放著不管
而是要持續地檢查
這檔股票
現在的狀況
在決定買進
或是賣出股票的時候
也不能只看一個指標
就直接下決定
而是要圍繞
三個核心來判斷
第一
公司的財報
經營狀況如何
這個叫做基本面
第二
這檔股票
是誰在買誰在賣
進場的是投信、大戶
還是散戶衝進來買
這個叫做籌碼面
第三個
現在股票的趨勢是什麼
買方和賣方
到底誰比較強
這個叫做技術面
這些條件
以前整理起來
非常複雜
都要一個一個
去看線圖找財報
但現在科技很發達了
網路上到處都有
選股的工具
你真正需要知道的
就只有一件事
我要設定什麼條件
才能快速篩選出
強勢的好股票
所以我特別開了一場
免費的線上直播講座
講座裡
我會用實際的畫面
一步一步教你
怎麼樣用
網路上就能找到
免費的選股工具
設定基本面技術面
跟籌碼面的條件
選出當天
或是這禮拜
即將開始
變強的股票
我也會跟你分享
我最常用的
五種方法
教你判斷股價走勢
找出買點
連結在
影片下方的資訊欄
你可以先點進去
報名卡位
不用花錢
時間到了
直接點進去看就好
如果這支影片
對你有幫助
記得幫我按讚一下
有什麼想聽的
也可以在下方
留言告訴我
我是小王子
我們下次見